Sophie je l'avais notamment hypnotisé
devant Laurent et devant tous les
copains qui étaient là ce jour-là vous
avez fait quoi après non c'est
c'est donc Gérard Miller vous êtes
psychanalyste docteur en sciences
politique prof de philo je dis ça parce
que quand même c'est bien prof de philo
à l'Université Paris 8 hein vous faites
de la radio vous faites de la télé mais
vous êtes aussi auteur et vous publiez
chez Stock un livre qui s'appelle Mino
vous savez comment on
fait ah
merci je fais pour la première fois et
pour ma fille Coralie qui m'a dit papa
cette fois vraiment ne c'est pas ton
intéressant faisle je l'ai fait pour
elle alors le scoop du livre c'est vous
savez hypnotiser ah faites
gaffe un jour un jour un jour Gérard
Miller tombe sur le manuel de l'étudiant
magn dans un grenier et et vous essayez
avec votre petit copain Nicolas et et ça
marche et vous parvenez encore mieux à
faire oublier son prénom à Miranda qui
était la plus jolie fille de la classe
alors ça c'est absolument exact et je
n'ai jamais pratiqué l'hypnose je le
précise toujours avec des patients
puisque la psychanalyse a abandonné
définitivement l'hypnose et je ne
conseille à personne de pratiquer
l'hypnose pour des raisons
thérapeutiques mais il n'y a rien de
plus passionnant que de voir des
expériences d'hypnose et de voir la
facilité avec laquelle on peut en
quelques instants paralyser un bras
donner à quelqu'un le sentiment de voler
ou d'autres choses tout aussi étonnante
à priori lorsqu'on pratique l'hypnose et
j'ai souvent fait à l'université un
cours sur ce qu'on appelle la généalogie
de la psychanalyse c'est la naissance un
petit peu de la psychanalyse Charco
Mesmer tout ça Charco en effet et je
montrais aux étudiants comment il y a
chez chacun nous une sorte de
suggestibilité à fleur de peau et qu'en
quelques instants on arrive à provoquer
des effets de de suggestion absolu ouais
vous pouvez provoquer quoi comme comme
effet par exemple bah ce que je décris
dans le livre c'està-dire les les les
les effets les plus simples c'est on
effit des paralysies des sentiments de
de par exemple de boire de l'eau quand
on a strictement rien dans la bouche ni
dans la main les sentiments très
étranges ce qui fascinait Freud et c'est
ce que je raconte dans le livre c'est ce
qu'on appelle les suggestions
post-thypnotiques vous hypnotisez
quelqu'un et sous hypnose vous lui dites
dans 1 heure dans 2h ou dans 3h
peut-être éventuellement plus moi je
l'ai fais au maximum sur 3h à un moment
donné quand je dirai le mot champignon
vous aurez l'envie de vous asseoir par
terre où que vous soyez et 2h 3h plus
tard lorsque vous prononcez le mot
champignon je prends cet exemple là la
personne ressent irrésistiblement
l'envie de faire ça et ça fascinait
freux de savoir pourquoi quelque chose
qu'on mettait finalement dans l'esprit à
un moment donné pouvait agir comme ça de
retard comme les médicament eff retard
exactement et ça bouleversait la
conception qu'on a du carartésianisme
puisquen général dans le cartésianisme
on dit quand la cause cesse l'effet
cesse et là la cause n'est plus là et
pourtant il y a un effet qui continue et
j'ai fait un certain nombre
d'expériences posst hypnotiques comme ça
qui sont assez intéress ça vous
intéresse ça je sens hein oh oui hein ça
m'a toujours intéressé le c'est son côté
sa mère est de la Réunion c'est son côté
vaudou voyez très rationaliste ouais
ouais c'est très rationaliste l'hypnose
vous en faites encore là sérieusement
j'en fais absolument pas pour des
raisons thérapeutiques je vous l'ai dit
j'en fais lorsqu'on m'en demande plutôt
amicalement mais Laurent Ruquier par
exemple lorsqu'on était on part souvent
en vacances les uns avec les autres je
crois que je peux le dire parce que on
connaît Sophie fort qui est une
chanteuse brillante comédienne brillante
et Sophie je l'avais notamment hypnotisé
devant Laurent et devant tous les
copains qui étaient là ce jour-là vous
avez fait quoi après
non en tout bien tout honneur ne cignez
rien et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
deardbe abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu